the thing about directing is time is  ticking and you got to wrangle the  actors  hi I'm glad you're here are you never  thought I'd hear those words come out of  your mouth so this season I'm directing  episode three and it came to be because  Larry called me and asked me if I was  interested in selecting one of the  episodes this year I'm with a bunch of  stiffs the food sucks the drinks aren't  strong enough in your hand is up my ass  it was really amazing seeing the whole  world of it because I got to hang out  with the crew some of the crew I I'd  really didn't know very well and then by  the end of the shoots like I'd rather be  hanging out at the camera track then at  crafty with  [Music]